who's telling the truth about ukraine
russia and the u.s are both accused of
manipulating facts to fan the flames of
war so who will win the information
battle for public opinion
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum it's often said that the
first casualty of war is the truth with
tensions running high over a potential
russian invasion of ukraine all sides
have accused each other of spreading
misinformation and propaganda here are
some examples
the separatist leaders of the donbass
region ordered mass evacuations to
southern russia they say the ukrainian
military is preparing to move into the
area kiev denies this and the u.s calls
the evacuation operation a false flag
operation by russia to justify military
action
moscow has long said ukraine is
threatening russian speakers even
accusing kiev of genocide
allow me to add that in our assessment
what's happening now in the donbass
constitutes genocide
the u.s called the genocide claim a
reprehensible falsehood
the state department says russia is
behind a huge disinformation campaign
but washington has faced criticism as
well the u.s says moscow could invade at
any moment joe biden repeated the
warning despite ukraine's president
saying such information is sowing
unnecessary fear
we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital kyiv
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
and do you have any indication about
whether president putin has made a
decision on whether to invade do you
feel confident that he that he hasn't
made that decision already
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
some journalists are questioning the use
of flawed intelligence by comparing the
situation to the u.s invasion of iraq in
2003
is their need to provide some underlying
evidence of just what you're seeing that
shows americans this is a country that
went through iraq and and concerns about
what the intelligence is showing
does the administration see a need to
just provide underlying intelligence
well let me just start with a
fundamental distinction between the
situation in iraq and the situation
today
in the situation in iraq intelligence
was used and deployed from this very
podium to start a war
we are trying to stop a war to prevent a
war to en to avert a war and all we can
do is come here before you and give good
faith and share everything that we know
to the best of our ability while
protecting sources and methods so we
continue to get the access to
intelligence we need
all right let's bring in our guests lada
roslinski is founder and managing
partner at black trident defense and
security consulting group she joins us
from kiev
richard sakwa is a professor of russian
and european politics at the university
of kent he joins us from kent in the
united kingdom and joining us by skype
from munich is peter zalmayev executive
director at the eurasia democracy
initiative a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story london let me start with
you today tensions right now are soaring
about the situation with regard to
russia and ukraine from your vantage
point
is there anybody when it comes to the
disinformation and misinformation war
that's going on between the us and
russia that is actually winning this
battle at the
moment um
there can be no winner in a
psychological operation that terrorizes
a population of millions tens of
millions of people so right now no no
winners only losers
peter um moscow has accused ukraine of
plotting a genocide against ethnic
russians and denounced ukrainians as
nazi sympathizers
this is the narrative that is being
advanced by russian media outlets you
hear this more and more each and every
day
what else are we hearing when it comes
to russian disinformation about ukraine
well first of all obviously you have to
understand that this is a complete line
of fabrication i am originally from the
east of ukraine i'm a russian-speaking
ukrainian-american uh from donetsk
originally so there's no genocide going
on there it never never happened there
it is obvious what we're hearing from
moscow and obviously
is i mean what we're seeing from moscow
is attempts to
uh you know uh make you uh ukrainians
panic make ukrainians afraid um you know
there's current constant flow of
information including coming from
washington that we still haven't been
able to verify the veracity of such as
that russia has plans to invade the
entire country they're preparing lists
of all those uh activists such as myself
for example who are based in kiev uh who
have been critical of russia that would
be the first should russia invade they
would be the first to be arrested
disappeared shot etc so there is a
there's a there's that campaign of
intimidation that we're seeing that is i
think a crucial component of putin's
strategy whether he orders a full
country invasion or
or not
a lot i saw you nodding along to a lot
of what peter was saying there it looked
like you wanted to jump in so please go
ahead
yeah
it is um quite terrorizing to hear about
these lists and that having been said
however
we do need to look back at what happened
in 2014
when the russian
special agents were abducting
assassinating ukrainians on moss in the
currently uncontrolled territories so it
is frightening it's completely
unpleasant it does help in a matter of
protecting for instance earlier people
had all of their friends phone numbers
in their telephones or on their sim
cards people that such as activists who
could potentially be on these lists are
probably a little bit more keen on not
having that information on them should
they be abducted richard you know
western governments have been very vocal
lately about trying to out russian
online disinformation tactics this this
is quite different than the response in
the past is this amped up response
because of the fact that moscow has been
successful in tilting public opinion
around geopolitical issues in the past
well there's two things there on the
geopolitics
this language of disinformation
misinformation is misleading in some
cases it's useful yes and we'll come
back to that but
what a lot of it is is a different
perspective on the geopolitical
situation and the larger historical
context and we talked about the 2014
events and even there just a statement
that was just said is massively
exaggerated and we know that it was a
terrible conflict uh and in the maidan
uh the way that in the end the shooting
came from the made down insurgents
themselves as a lot of evidence has
shown so it's an absolutely appalling
situation but the key point is that
sometimes uh you it's very dangerous to
use the language of disinformation when
it's simply policy disagreements and
this goes back not just to putin it goes
back to yeltsin and it goes back to the
larger geopolitical context of uh nato
enlargement
so i mean i agree that the situation is
absolutely appalling and have every
sympathy for the inhabitants of ukraine
but then also for russia which has been
suffering for years of sanctions when
these sanctions are how a lot of them
have been imposed to ensure that russia
fulfills the minsk accords when it was
obviously kiev which had to take the
initiative on them and so that is unjust
and so i think we need to step back a
bit from this language of disinformation
which has been going on for many years
it's not just been amped up now it's
worse now than it has been before let's
listen to the serious arguments and i
think both sides have exaggerated
massively let's call it what an
old-fashioned word
propaganda lada i saw you uh shaking
your head uh to some of what uh richard
was saying there so it looked like you
wanted to jump in again so go ahead
yes thank you
first and foremost no country after the
second world war has changed
international borders so when we discuss
geopolitics in human civil political
rights uh the russian federation does
have a lot to explain and be held
accountable for including the terrible
tragedy of mh17
that having been said i believe that
globally
truth has been deconstructed completely
so of course everybody has a right to
their perspective everybody has a right
to their opinion at the end of the day
it is the responsibility of wise people
with integrity to know the truth and
defend human civil political rights
which have been codified after the
atrocities of the first and second world
war this is very important
peter um u.s intelligence agencies have
been declassifying information saying
that they believe that vladimir putin
plans to invade ukraine and then they've
been sharing it widely
is this strategy because because this
does seem to be a pretty big change in
strategy from the past
is this making it more difficult for
vladimir putin to justify an invasion
i'm visiting the munich security
conference and i just stepped away from
a ukrainian luncheon that is happening
right now with the former dignitaries
former uh defense minister james mattis
uh
general david petraeus mitchell coleba
the ukrainian foreign minister just
arrived and will be speaking so there's
a lot of talk about western unity uh in
support of ukraine and it seems like
most most folks are on board with joe
biden's strategy which i'll tell you as
uh just as a private person it's been
hard for me to be taking to be opening
up new york times every morning and to
see that an invasion is happening it's
imminent it's going to happen any day
now now we're talking about these lists
you know um of people who will be
disappeared should uh put an invade
obviously this is part of the strategy
whether putin invades or not it's
already working uh it's not it's working
not only in ukraine and on ukrainian
minds but it's working on officials
minds throughout the world uh you know
so that that's what you call a credible
threat whether there is a you know an
invasion in mind that vladimir putin has
you cannot discount this as a as a as a
as a possibility even though by all
accounts it seems like it will be a
suicidal step for vladimir putin simply
because he just won't be able to uh okay
he'll be able to invade a part of
ukraine's territory will he be able to
occupy it for any long period of time
that's a much harder question and let me
just very briefly respond to the
previous speaker when we mentioned minsk
agreements and who mentioned that both
sides have sinned when it comes to
disinformation let me just ask maybe a
rhetorical question or maybe a direct
question to him does he really believe
what's happening in the east of ukraine
with the shelling of civilian population
centers that ukraine as as as
the kremlin claims that ukraine is now
doing this after having a hundred almost
200 000 russian troops on the borders
does he really believe that ukraine is
attacking that is disinformation in
action that is the false flag operation
in full view that biden the biden's
administration has been worrying about
we're seeing it you know in real time
richard that's a direct question to you
from peter so i'm going to let you go
ahead and respond
well i'm going to go back a couple of
steps uh ladder said now again with the
overall sentiment that we have to base
every analysis on facts but the question
at the moment and this intense war fever
on all sides uh has uh led to the
distortion effects the borders have
changed we've seen it with kosovo we've
seen it with goa we've seen it with a
whole stack of other elements it's not
to justify it but simply to say that
the borders have been changed and it's
appalling because the 1945 system
precisely tries to avoid forced and non
uh
consensual moving of borders as for mh17
it's an absolute tragedy but are we
suggesting that they went out that day
the insurgents to shoot down a civilian
airliner obviously not the aim was as an
intensive intensifying war uh we know
that there were the geneva accords of
april 2014 which ukraine walked away
from there was a deal on the table which
could have avoided all of this and yet
they failed to achieve and to talk to
their own people in the donbass they
failed to talk to their own citizens in
the donbass which could have avoided
this appalling conflict and as for the
shelling now we know that for years now
they've been mutual shelling on both
sides that donetsk is right on the front
line at the moment uh is right on the
front line and citizens and civilians
have been under shelling and flying in
sniper attacks for years
and we had to sort it out and the
failure of germany and france in
particular to put pressure on kiev to
fulfill what we're talking about a very
basic normal thing which is a level of
devolution it can happen in italy it can
happen in spain it can happen in canada
for some reason we give ukraine a pass
when we could have found a diplomatic
solution and so we end up today with
this appalling situation where you have
i don't know where the figure of 200 000
but we certainly have far too many
forces on the side we have 130 000
ukrainian troops also uh i'm facing
against uh they don't donate the
donation richard so it's
dangerously dangerous
i'm sorry to interrupt you but but but
lada wants to jump in go ahead
yes i think it's really would be nice of
you to answer the question that that you
were asked and actually every country
has a right to have an army
and the fact that ukraine has one and is
defending it is actually something that
every single country should be doing not
surrounding foreign countries and
threatening them with cyber attacks
psychological attacks killing abduction
please answer the question that our
co-person has asked you i would i'm also
very curious to hear how you will answer
it
richard did you want to respond to that
well to the specific question yes i do
believe at the moment that uh the
shelling which uh has been taking place
uh there has been misattribution but my
point is that later you must understand
the context which is the fact that the
donbass
are ukrainian citizens of course now
seven hundred thousand dollars have
russian passports but i'm astonished
that kiev has not been able to talk to
its own people it wants these parts back
it wants these two parts of these two uh
obelisks back and yet they refuse to
talk to their own people citizens whom
they claim are their own it's it's it's
been a dead end and so clearly at the
moment we're in a moment of
extraordinary war fever so there's
disinformation and lies um going on and
as for forces being allowed to mobilize
russia of course apart from those in uh
in the belarus are on their own
territory and can i just mention one
other thing about the munich security
conference richard richard let me let me
let me let you get to that point in a
bit because we are starting to run out
of time and i do want to ask peter a
question here peter
from your perspective um is it
counterproductive for the u.s and for
nato to continue to state that they
believe that an invasion is imminent
i mean has that helped or has that hurt
uh listen uh once again we're in
uncharted waters and even the washington
will admit that this sort of sort of uh
megaphone diplomacy that they've engaged
in has not been tried to that same
extent before only history will judge in
the next few days weeks months we will
know uh my take is that you know we are
probably still not looking at a full
country invasion simply because putin is
probably incapable of doing it right now
it's gonna come with a very high cost we
are in for the long haul for as long as
vladimir putin is in power he will not
be at peace with
an independent ukraine you have to
understand that uh so uh when while
while i say that about the informational
you know policy i will say that there is
a there needs to be a note of caution
inserted into the sanctions policy and
this is something that fiona hill donald
trump's former security adviser said
that you know uh when it comes to the
sanctions policy whether signaling that
sanctions are coming regardless of what
vladimir putin does may backfire simply
because russians will think well we have
nothing to lose let's go ahead so there
needs to be some note of caution uh
there is a i'm seeing a somewhat
optimistic sign that vladimir uh that mr
lavrov and bla and blanken are supposed
to meet on the 24th of february so
the hope is that nothing will happen
before then and for as long as diplomats
are talking the guns are states are
staying silent let me just one one more
minute just to refer once again to what
this previous speaker said when he
continues harping on the issue while the
ukrainian government has refused and
again to speak with ostensible you know
uh people of the donbass there are no
people of the dumbass to speak with
these are prophet regimes that that are
controlled directly from moscow and the
part of the strategy is to push this
minsk agreements down ukraine's throats
uh which will be the same and will
return to tantamount to ukraine's
capitulation through other less painful
you know means for russia short of an
invasion minsk means a stop to ukraine's
aspirations uh to have an independent
foreign policy to become a member of
nato and to become a member of the eu
lada let me ask you a similar question
uh to what i just asked peter from your
perspective are there inherent risks to
this campaign by the u.s by nato by
other western countries i mean if these
warnings about an imminent invasion
continue to grow more dire and an
invasion does not happen
what does that do
well
it's discrediting the
state system at the end of the day
on an international global
level
internally what it does to the citizens
who are the victims of this type of
diplomacy or propaganda as you will
is actually quite quite heavy people are
exhausted people are terrified uh
and actually the level of anti-american
rhetoric has been raising in the couple
in the past few weeks
particularly not only because of this um
abundance of information and and the
addressing of which date it's going to
happen which is completely ridiculous uh
also the
the perception that ukraine has been
abandoned by its main western allies by
them pulling out of kiev by pulling out
of the special monitoring mission of the
osce
rather than really supporting and
calling more experts into ukraine into
kiev the fact that they have pulled out
and have now placed themselves in viv
not all of them but but most western
allies have either already moved to
leave or considering doing so
which again creates this uh perception
that is going to be so much easier to
kill the people
in the the the city um because we don't
have our allies here to protect us they
should have sent more smm
monitors rather than pulling them out
richard i know you had a point you
wanted to finish making i'll let you do
that but i also want to ask you when it
comes to
the fact that the u.s
that other western countries have been
so public in sharing this intelligence
that they have gathered how unusual is
that
um well i mean it's uh intelligence we
know in the russiagate uh a business the
intelligence kept being fed out into the
public domain and we know as it's been
even admitted by some washington
officials that uh the media is complicit
together with uh infamous so-called
information from the security services
which is uh
as we saw with the alleged collusion
between trump and putin in 2016 it
turned out to be utterly false and i'm
not saying it's false now i'm simply
saying it's part of this new method so
there's nothing particularly new about
suddenly the anglo-american use of
intelligence fed into the media to
achieve a certain political effects
as for the larger issue can i just say
as for minsk and i think one of the
previous speakers uh was very honest and
saying that minsk are unimplementable
then a simple question emerges every six
months the european union has been
smashing sanctions onto russia for its
failure to fulfill minsk and now we have
it quite openly well um kiev had no
intention ever and i understand the
arguments by the way why uh min kiev
wouldn't like to implement links because
clearly it was a forced solution and
there's other issues involved but at
least let's be honest and i'm glad to
hear the honesty emerging that minsk was
not going to be implemented fine let's
find some other format in which we can
return these donbass um parts to
ukrainian sovereignty while ensuring
that the uh issues within the donbass
you know that there's a fair solution in
that society as for the munich security
conference the failure way back in
february 2017 exactly 15 years ago when
putin uh made that famous speech
denouncing a unipolar world and all the
rest the fact that at that moment there
was unity against him and everybody was
so proud that putin's attempt to do i
have a wedge between the partners and
look it's not a question of driving
wedges or unity this unity at the moment
is the unity on the march of folly let's
listen to the serious arguments and i
absolutely agree with the previous
speaker the diplomatic process is
continuing with a meeting hopefully by
the end of next week
uh peter um we just have about a minute
30 seconds left uh let me just ask you
when it comes to the pro-kremlin
disinformation machine how does the
domestic disinformation operation differ
from the foreign media operation
if you're asking about ukraine right yes
uh well
you know um
so far i mean what we've actually seen
has been a sort of tension between
ukraine the ukrainian central government
and or the the american administration
uh the behind by the biden's white house
uh the vladimir putin has been at pains
to actually keep ukrainians calm and up
to till now even now that tensions have
risen uh there's much more concern now
uh including on the streets of ukrainian
cities the government the ministry of
defense continues insisting that they're
not seeing signs of an imminent invasion
let alone by
occupation of the entire country so
there's a little bit of attention that
viewers should be aware about
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests lada roslinski richard
sakwa and peter salmayev
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
mohammed jamjum the whole team here bye
for now
[Music]
you